[Música]
hola soy nota la cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida a que américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy empezamos hablando de
colombia porque tras la llegada a la
presidencia de gustavo petro cambia su
política de drogas y se enfocará en
perseguir a los traficantes más que a
los cultivadores de la hoja de coca y a
los consumidores sin que esto represente
una ruptura con el aliado histórico en
la guerra contra el narcotráfico eeuu
les explicamos
y vamos a argentina donde cientos de
personas salieron a las calles en apoyo
a la ex presidenta y actual
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner sobre que empieza una petición
de 12 años de prisión por parte de la
fiscalía en un supuesto caso de
corrupción les explicamos el proceso de
la mano de nuestro corresponsal en
buenos aires y visitamos el jugador
porque un grupo de danza folklórica hace
activismo por los derechos de la
comunidad lgbt más utilizan las
tradiciones andinas contra la
discriminación desde quitó nuestro
corresponsal nos trae la historia
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal en un importante giro
eeuu reconoció esta semana que la
política antidrogas en américa del sur
específicamente en colombia no ha sido
exitosa y ha contribuido a la
estigmatización desde bogotá el director
de la oficina de control de drogas de la
casa blanca anunció el inicio de una
nueva era en la llamada guerra contra
los estupefacientes a través de una
inversión por 2 millones de dólares en
el nuevo programa que con este fin se
implementará en los próximos tres años
escuchamos sus palabras el presidente es
consciente que muchas de las políticas
del pasado han marginalizado a algunas
personas y ha no han trabajado para
muchas poblaciones y lo podemos hacer
mejor la administración baile es una
está en una nueva era sobre la política
de luz que es holística basada en
ciencias compasiva y enfocada en las
personas el anuncio se da tras la
llegada del presidente gustavo petro a
la casa de nariño quien desde el día de
su posesión afirmó que a su juicio el
enfoque de la guerra contra las drogas
fracasó pues a las mafias y
recientemente agregó que debía perseguir
sea los criminales y no a los campesinos
y a los consumidores escuchemos la
policía nacional no está para llegar a
una casa de una familia campesina y
porque cultivo hoja de coca
arrastrarlos hasta las cárceles 25 por
ciento de los presos en las cárceles son
campesinos de colombia eso lo único que
va a provocar son unas guerras secretas
clandestinas en los barrios una
confrontación
permanente y creciente entre una
ciudadanía joven y un personal de la
policía joven y esa no es nuestra guerra
y esta misma semana la policía
colombiana anunció que ahora priorizar a
la erradicación manual y la sustitución
voluntaria de los cultivos de coca en
acciones concertadas con las comunidades
en 2015 el gobierno de juan manuel
santos había ordenado detener la
aspersión de los cultivos ilícitos
basándose en el argumento de que el
glifosato del herbicida que se utiliza
para fumigación puede ser cancerígeno
para los seres humanos y causar daños al
medio ambiente como lo advirtió la
organización mundial de la salud el
gobierno de iván duque intentó retomar
las pero la corte constitucional se lo
impidió
colombia es el mayor productor de hoja
de coca en el mundo la materia prima de
la cocaína- y le siguen perú y bolivia
casi el 99% de la cocaína colombiana es
enviada ilegalmente a eeuu y europa por
los cárteles del narcotráfico miren en
2021 según la oficina de política
nacional para el control de las drogas
de la casa blanca en colombia había
234 mil hectáreas en perú 84 mil
hectáreas y en bolivia 39 mil hectáreas
en cuanto a la producción de cocaína en
colombia en 2021 se produjeron 972
toneladas en perú
785 y en bolivia 317
precisamente en bolivia los cultivadores
de la hoja de coca reactivaron sus
protestas esta semana que han terminado
en graves enfrentamientos con la policía
la asociación departamental de
productores de coca adepcoca asegura que
las leyes bolivianas sólo reconocen el
mercado tradicional de villa fátima en
la paz y de sacaba en cochabamba por lo
que exigen que un mercado que consideran
paralelo se cierre desde la paz nuestra
corresponsal meriva k nos explica que
estipula la ley sobre el cultivo de la
hoja de coca y esta misma ley la ley de
la coca permite que en bolivia existan
dos mercados para la comercialización de
la hoja para el consumo tradicional es
decir para el boleo o pijcheo masticado
de la hoja de coca uno de esos mercados
según la ley debe estar ubicado en
sacaba cochabamba donde se vende la coca
del chapare cuyo máximo dirigente es el
ex presidente evo morales y el otro
mercado debe estar ubicado en el barrio
de villa fátima de la ciudad de la paz
donde se vende la coca de los
productores de los yungas del
departamento de la paz
dónde está la zona de consumo y de
producción tradicional pues sucede que
estos productores de los yungas que
están agrupados en la asociación de
adepcoca desde el año 2017 se han
convertido en duros críticos del
entonces gobierno de evo morales y ahora
también del gobierno de luís arce porque
evo morales- legalizó la coca del
chapare y ellos consideraron que eso era
una competencia desleal para ellos pues
evo morales cuando era presidente inició
el enjuiciamiento incluso el
encarcelamiento de algunos dirigentes de
adepcoca y en paralelo impulsó el
partido oficialista a la creación de una
nueva asociación de productores de coca
en los yungas y esta asociación que
también se llama de coca decidió
instalar un nuevo mercado para la venta
de coca en el barrio de villa del carmen
de la paz pues los productores de coca
de adepcoca que están ubicados en villa
fátima no están de acuerdo con ese
mercado y por eso es que protestan ya el
año pasado han protagonizado violentas
protestas y enfrentamientos con la
policía y este año ya llevan cuatro
semanas de duros enfrentamientos porque
exigen que ese mercado al que consideran
ilegal y paralelo debe cerrarse pero en
la policía que responde obviamente al
gobierno de luisa se está protegiendo
los predios de ese mercado paralelo para
evitar que a de coca de villa fátima
arremeta contra ese mercado y lo
destruya ese es el fondo del problema en
bolivia para que haya enfrentamientos
diariamente entre los productores de
coca de los yungas es decir como se
comercializa quien comercializa cuándo y
dónde comercializa la hoja de coca para
el consumo tradicional la otra la que es
ilegal pues se presume que va
directamente al narcotráfico y esa coca
no entra en las consideraciones de este
conflicto vamos ahora a argentina para
revisar la cifra de la semana 12 esa es
la cantidad de años de prisión que la
fiscalía pide para la vicepresidenta
cristina fernández por supuestamente
liderar junto a su esposo el fallecido
ex presidente néstor kirchner una
asociación ilícita a través de la cual
se habría defraudado al estado más de
mil millones de dólares en el
otorgamiento de contratos de obras
públicas la fiscalía pidió además la
inhabilitación para ejercer cargos
públicos para la vicepresidenta desde
buenos aires nuestro corresponsal
natalio cost hoy nos explica que sigue
en el proceso
todavía falta mucho para que haya
definiciones
concluyentes en este caso ya terminaron
los alegatos de la fiscalía y ahora en
septiembre
comenzarán los alegatos de las defensas
de los 13 imputados entre los que está
la ex presidenta y actual vicepresidenta
cristina fernández el de su defensa se
estima que comenzará a fines de
septiembre o principios de octubre la
fiscalía para el caso de cristina
fernández pidió 12 años de prisión e
inhabilitación de por vida para ejercer
cargos públicos su defensa argumentará
que es inocente y que la fiscalía está
equivocada y el tribunal cuando llegue
el momento luego de otras instancias
procesales tendrá que decidir a quien le
da la razón haga lo que haga
para después de luego apelar en la
instancia superior que es la de casación
y aún en ese caso sí casación le diera
la razón a una parte de la otra la que
esté en desacuerdo puede ir a la corte
suprema de justicia así que estamos
hablando de al menos meses para tener
una definición un cierre de este caso
que ha generado un importante terremoto
político en argentina la expresidenta se
alió va a ser una defensa pública a
través de sus redes sociales el martes
pasado sectores del peronismo de todo el
país se han movilizado dando alertas
públicas de que salen en defensa de la
que consideran en su líder más
importante y sectores de la oposición
han salido por su parte en defensa de la
fiscalía diciendo que la fiscalía está
siendo atacada y cuestionada y que se
debe dejar trabajar a la justicia y este
terremoto político no cesa y está
totalmente presente en este momento de
que a ver si en algún momento va a
amainar o va a acompañar lo que resta de
esta causa judicial en los meses por
venir
en ecuador un grupo de danza folklórica
se ha convertido en el símbolo del
activismo por los derechos de la
comunidad lgtb más que utilizan las
tradiciones andinas para generar
aceptación social y enfrentar la
discriminación se hacen llamar ecuador
de colores desde quito nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega nos trae la
historia
poner cayambe por favor edison en un día
de las indicaciones para el ensayo final
de los es el líder de una agrupación de
18 bailarines que interpretan las
tradiciones indígenas a través de la
danza crea un refugio seguro para la
comunidad el gp y con más de la que
también forma parte se visten de mujer
mientras se apropian de la cosmovisión
andina bailan por el reconocimiento y la
aceptación social porque sentimos que
habiendo tanta riqueza en nuestro país
tanta identidad cultural tantos
personajes nuestros pueblos indígenas
que están vivos que son parte que son
latente que es un gran porcentaje de
nuestro país entonces nosotros lo
queremos tomar como parte ya que es tan
nuestro para identificar y para
visibilizar a nuestra comunidad glp
comunidad donde roberto calero encontró
refugio hace 7 años luego que su familia
lo rechazará por su orientación sexual
con la ayuda de edinson hoy se
transforma entre máscaras y atuendos
folclóricos para hacer realidad su sueño
de bailar es un refugio y también es mi
pasión
siempre he anhelado en bailar en algún
grupo muy importante y el pólipo de
decir que estoy muy contento muy feliz y
muy realizado al realizar este arte
transformista mediante la danza
en ecuador 70% de la comunidad el gmt y
cunas aseguró haber sido rechazada por
su orientación sexual también han
sufrido de actos de violencia amenazas o
detenciones arbitrarias según datos del
instituto nacional de estadística ine
el rechazo la comunidad sexo diversa ha
logrado que personas heterosexuales como
pablo carvajal se unen a este grupo de
danza con el fin de dar apoyo a la
diversidad yo lo estoy ayudando a
maquillar pero también los estoy
acompañando en escenarios enfrentando a
la crítica que a veces es un poco dura
entre la comunidad y de la sociedad
hacia ellos
estos bailarines no se rendirán ante el
objetivo de educar sobre la
discriminación arraigada en un país
donde ya se reconoce la identidad género
y el matrimonio entre parejas del mismo
sexo
[Música]
gracias por acompañarme en aquí américa
en la producción estuvieron andrés
doncel y diana rodríguez pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom por favor
envíenme sus comentarios en redes
sociales a la dirección que ven en su
pantalla y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]
soy francisco zacarías